this week we got bad manners lying actor
and hidden teeth and teeth though all
actors lie with the performance cuz if
know they're just liars you're an actor
I'm not really an actor I want to be one
but I'm not really are you ready to lie
uh yeah I'm already a liar okay are you
are you really do you really want to be
an actor
no not really yeah he is a liar he was I
want to be you know you know what my
dream thing is I want to be like Adam
Sandler where you don't really have to
act you just write the story around you
and you fit perfectly in that world it
sounds like you two to be minute yeah of
it because I think youtubers they think
they're here so they write this world
but then when they plug themselves in
you know I okay this guy's doesn't even
have the chops to be in the world that
they think they're in yeah first story
this video on Twitter we've been
circling around because of how atrocious
it atrocious Oh caption something to
think about the next time you eat at the
salad bar oh is that the buffet line
pretty much looks like a white guy
but the the manner is of Asian behavior
hit it nice want exam and wait for it
buddy yeah you'll drink oh oh oh you
know what you are so crazy that only
solidified my my like assumption that
that pink that's what people did my
whole life I thought you were gonna say
that made you want to drink it cause he
like my mom told me never to get food
from there because it's probably gross
oh never ever ever in a supermarket
gotten super-ship no places like that
and that's the reason why you know it's
crazy to like it's like twelve twelve
dollars a pound and somebody coughed on
it I'm like what I don't want this [ __ ]
give me the ingredients it's like movie
theater popcorn yeah you see those cats
like with the
and they're like arm is getting in the
popcorn wall they scoop it out with the
metal thing I'll [ __ ] greasy you like
oh my god what butter on that and like
you know what I also don't like
restaurants when they like the server
gives you your leg drink but then they
hold it around the brim work oh you
drink it and I'm like oh [ __ ] get a
straw please [ __ ] yeah are you guys
carrying your own straws now nah [ __ ]
that no I just drink it out of all those
pop the question do people do that dude
really it's like happening man oh I
think people I like the retractable
straw that's pretty stupid but I have
it's like this big but then they put it
in their bag or whatever and then you
attract it I don't like the taste of
metal straws there's a taste to it it
tastes funny
it tastes like [ __ ] sale but have you
tried the paper straws like the ones
that they like terrible yeah they fall
apart
so it's like you have a time limit on
like how fast you got to drink that [ __ ]
cuz otherwise it's just all part
immediately I appreciate what they're
doing with it though I think it's pretty
cool when they do have it it's just like
if you're somebody that holds a drink
for a while the paper straws are
probably not the best thing for you
what's the main purpose to save the
seagulls or whatever it's a lot of
plastic oh dude people can blow me that
was using like some paper straws too for
a bit and it'll cool they're like
decorative stuff but they did tend to
fall apart but you know people want to
save the earth and that's what you get
the plastic bag ban is the biggest
[ __ ] joke dude they actually have
like a study that they did with that
show that the banning the plastic bag
thing does nothing for the ecosystem
I'll put it like this don't you ever
[ __ ] come up to an Asian person about
that [ __ ] never really actually reuse it
like a [ __ ] timely yeah the same
bag that says [ __ ] rounds on it I'll
reuse it and if I get like two juices
I'll wash it yeah I'll wash it again you
wash it hey do you reuse it flux is to
be widened throw it all away in the fine
white people I keep Ziploc so I wash I
throw
[ __ ] out I watched like six times
I retract it knows it's roar or like
what would you call that we have [ __ ]
well we have we hang it on the laundry
theme with the clothes pins to dry it
out yep put it in the clothesline put in
our dryer to just dry out like all 80 of
them at the same time that's not even
the old person thing that's just a sick
[ __ ] yeah is it weird that that
doesn't really determine me from yeah
that's [ __ ] really no that's not
weird because your [ __ ] weirdo you
would do this [ __ ] I would never do that
that's gross take the whole hand picked
up [ __ ] with your hand of course
we're not gonna bare hands I don't I
don't you have so many plastic bags why
don't I don't intrude on okay so [ __ ]
weird but then I'll be eating food right
and he see something that I like and he
goes oh can I try some of that I give
him the four key bypasses my four can
use his hands I've given you the utensil
but I haven't used it you go if we were
strangers all what I've used the utensil
okay that's a really beautiful thing
you're disgusting
I hope you wash it and he doesn't wash
that much this is this isn't washing his
hands and I guarantee this is what
happened you washed your hands
when you took a shower he hasn't watched
them since have used the restrooms in no
you haven't peed Oh in there yes would
you pee no I peed and I washed my hands
you did not washer well what a good boy
I always wash my hands after I pee I
believe you yeah do you think that this
guy watches so if like if this guy in
particular the soup eater guy if he's
watching a video of somebody else doing
that do you think he's like oh not only
he cares yeah he just cares about him
doing it I think he he looks like he's
hit that age where he doesn't give up
cuz he's like doing it in public and
he's brought in broad day it seems like
a normal day he's just like no and he
took like the whole [ __ ] day he
wasn't like tasting it he was like yeah
you didn't even think it was wrong cuz
he wasn't looking around he was just
like I'm in my own he did it twice well
he did the [ __ ] yeah you did a [ __ ]
three [ __ ] times he drank that whole
ladle but if he knows that he does this
he doesn't think the other people are
doing it then do it he doesn't care
yeah I don't think he might like Bridget
if that was like my supermarket all you
would have seen was that clip and you
would have heard this they didn't tell
them directly because they ended up
saying that they notified security right
away but they don't know if we didn't
notify I would be like hey you sick [ __ ]
going mad bro I never eat it but still I
think this guy's shame though he's gonna
shame that's what I'm saying like if the
person reporting this what a shame them
do you think you would have changes like
these ways you might have operatives for
the minute he would have been like oh I
owe and put it down but he would have
gone to the other supermarkets they
should tase him from the back while he's
doing it still would've drink that
silver you wanna yeah just wait a bit a
little hotter that's all yeah I love it
alright next story this actor does
anyone watch better call Saul yeah I
tried but we know what it is I tried we
watched the first episode same I think I
watch at first but it was really hard to
know we're trying to watched I cut at
the same time so I didn't really get the
whole episode in my brain hmm it was
playing but not yeah so an actor that
has been on that show he's saying that
there's a rapist if NATO know so they
miss Todd he claims that he's bipolar
and that he cut he cut off his arm and
cauterized Oh about 17 years ago and
since then he's been lying about how he
lost his arm he's been saying that he's
a war veteran oh and just to have like a
better story so he can get picked up as
for acting sounds like every actor in
Hollywood means Han that sucks yeah and
so now I get picked up for acting from
being a war veteran
well people sympathy yeah it sounds it's
I thought it looks like you're trying to
get like a Navy SEAL role I mean I could
see that right that's still the sim can
i play Bambi I cut I was in the [ __ ]
war and they're like what we should
consider him for Bambi yeah makes a good
point yes Todd no this is a screenshot
of the episode he was on and another one
I haven't gone this far yeah so he cut
off his own arm and so he cut off his
own arm when he was off his men and
that's the reason why he's coming out
with this he's like I know I'm
committing career suicide here but I
want him say he's like I'm killing my
career by doing this yeah and he's like
the reason why I want to I feel like
it's important for everyone to know the
reason why I don't have an arm is
because I feel like I've been
dishonorable and I also want people to
realize how important it is to take your
medication he's like I was off my meds
when I did this and it just happened so
fast so just you know if you well take
your meds like take your mentor Jesus my
choice it was probably manic but someone
that's bipolar like really clinically
bipolar it's pretty gnarly really yeah
like my sister has doubt cuz right now a
lot of people use that term things yes
they sure do I've known a thousand kids
who said they're bipolar dude yeah and
and um but my sister has clients that
she's like they're bipolar in the
[ __ ] more Airy I've witnessed it too
like during episode and it gets really
scary I notice on a TV a real episode I
know in real life someone having like a
what is it a manic episode
they're not to press rather manic I
don't know I do you're a depressive
romantic well the whole thing was like
this person thought that the world is
gonna end
kinda like leave and like you were just
like legit like just it was real in
their head it was really scary what do
you have to do you have to pick them
down and put a pill in their mouth or
what well they ended up going to the
mental gonna get committed yeah it's
pretty crazy that's [ __ ] right yeah
yeah but it's real and if that that's
what you saying this like I get it don't
stop taking your meds because I chopped
off my arm when I was off it that's
[ __ ] insane look at that he's a
sexual actor
how about that anymore I think that's
kind of cool that he's owning it I like
what people own kids good that he's
coming out with it especially since it's
not brought on by like well hopefully it
wasn't brought on by somebody like I
don't think that you're actually like
hopefully it was just of his own
volition yeah hopefully it's not like
it's like oh I found out this about you
I'm gonna leak it he's like I'm jumping
ahead yeah yeah well now it's it's it's
awesome that mental health is becoming
such a such a common conversation hat
because before if he would have said the
reason why he lost his arm people would
have been like wow this guy's loony like
we don't yeah especially seventeen years
ago yeah like no one would have even
considered him not even for a split
second well it's good they want to
better help comment I think yep I just
think it really helps out do you have
your own link really helpful I'm gonna
actually try it and I will use all it
for the four hundred dollar sign ups I
will use all that for a good cause so
what's a good cause my cowboy game
addiction hey Nicky by the way [ __ ] that
grasshopper dude I want to kill that
thing so bright where did this come from
I know just drawing all the plans tell
me about it what are you talking about
yard is just [ __ ] we got one more
topic yeah yeah what are you talking
about we could scrabble pay attention we
can trim whatever you took the
grasshopper tomorrow no I didn't take it
I want to know that little [ __ ] is
eating everything and acting like it's
all cool he's taking advantage of your
wife that's exactly what animals do
though they eat you don't eat
the [ __ ] plants that I bought well
how is this thing supposed to know
plants outside [ __ ] I'm the Train the
groundhog pick that [ __ ] up and
you chuck him out she did but then it
looked at her and then they had a
connection and then she cried hey guess
what in Thailand we eat those
[ __ ] right you're tiny yeah so
I think the other day she thought he was
he thought he was dead she was like sure
that he was dead because he wasn't
moving I was so four days yeah I was a
little thrilled but but you had to act
like you're like she knew you up
yeah Gary the [ __ ] is what I call I
can't forget because every day I get a
gary update she's alive he was not
moving I guess literally obliterated a
whole street yeah dude the whole thing's
gone man a bullet the [ __ ] that he
moved to another one so he can [ __ ]
destroy that one too I know and I'm like
where does it all go cuz like it's not
like he's shooting it on the ground and
I have the huge tree sized like yeah
bunch of [ __ ] crap from a cracker where
does it go what I don't know I don't
know how those work it's weird right
I'm a [ __ ] excused - yeah he's big shed
used to be a cute color green oh yeah
why is he so [ __ ] brown and tan I'm
just mad cause he doesn't weigh than me
anyways a Nicki he weighs yeah wizard
that's what she says anyway hey guys
watching all this on her story I just
live it man yeah I am in her stories bro
you are her story that's it for our last
story construction workers that were
renovating an old building in Georgia
discovered it's hot today and open this
wall they discovered an estimated 1,000
human teeth inside the wall holy [ __ ]
bags or oh my god smells so bad I don't
think it smelled not anymore because
like there's no more flesh on any of
them so there's no rotting ladies right
there's so much teeth and not one white
one oh yeah you're not no one is
white teeth though yeah they are if
they're yellow that means they're really
healthy did you know that I mean that's
super [ __ ] yellow but they're
supposed to have it but the Tigers teeth
were all bright white when they came out
are they bright white yeah they're white
right now what is [ __ ] dude never have
seen Ty Lee speed your kids let me help
you there Tyrese Tyrese got some white
teeth probably why he killed him you
would have liked any more like like his
teeth when they kick the [ __ ] white
as [ __ ] to come up almost yeah that's
true they're pretty sorry
is he unhealthy is what you say and he
smiles like a healthy it smiling you
know be underbite smile some more photos
here the building is that Philadelphia
no Georgia oh did they look at the old
like building records to see how they
were it was used before
there's an old dentist's office well we
feel better so it was well I put it in
the walls though exactly
you know what's crazy that that wasn't
this isn't the first time they've
discovered this what there's been two
other times in the area or like in
Georgia that they've found teeth in the
wall do they gonna find this dentist
that's like moving locations and be like
you start off [ __ ] foot do you think
this is like do you want to keep these
teeth and like now he's like yeah
probably do about it what happens to
your teeth it's like they usually give
it to you yeah they ask you okay what if
you don't want it what do they do I
thought they threw it away
put it in the wall they throw it away
now I you don't see a little there's
always a little hole out of that office
batiko yeah so they're saying that this
building was once occupied by dentists
in 1900 feels better and then I know it
does feel better
do we like to play by a different
dentist up until at least 1930 he added
to it yeah it makes probably it's a
Georgia tradition yeah it's pretty weird
because yeah like I said there was other
two other instances there's been other
instances where they found other items
in homes dating back to the 1870s like
razor blades or it's not as crazy as
like human remains
what would you think if you like your
new house and you're just like doing
some construction it's just like opened
up a wall just all these teeth like I'd
be like I get a discount
I better get a discount for this should
call up your realtor you like are you
seeing this [ __ ] yeah I would play it up
Frank get a discount
I love that [ __ ] bet you have zillion
teeth my father budget teeth my huh me
this story to tell people now yeah I'm
as so [ __ ] cool and this is where we
found all those teeth yep yeah I want to
be that old person right where they
coming to the house by the way
it's a tourist trap that's pretty cool
the house of PEEP so they're saying that
they're gonna be taken to a Historical
Museum these teeth from 1890 yeah I mean
like whoa I mean where would you take
them otherwise yeah it's what is it
other way where else would you take them
away that's the display because because
they're so old they go historic now I
guess I don't know but they're pretty
much thing that they want to try to do
DNA testing yeah that'd be cool give it
back to their family that's such a waste
of money there's some museums some
museums like hey this ain't the Lincoln
museum we gotta have an angle yeah
there's only so many of those artifacts
and they're all in love Smithsonian yeah
yeah it's gonna be at the London County
Historical Society Museum sounds like
one of those yeah right
do you think no it's not the Mafia
Museum at the [ __ ] flamingo is the
shittiest Museum that was pretty cool
that sounds sick though that was dope
you would think oh it didn't meet our
expectations what do they have in there
possibly what did somebody needs to tell
you how tall like Bugsy Siegel really
was now a little artifact the story goes
like this is Bonnie and Clyde's
toothbrush I'll be damned
one pink in one blue but I should be
pretty surprised with a brush there did
you know they had teeth like you guys
got their hat and they're like no sorry
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]